what if the mosasaurus were still alive
this creature went extinct millions of
years ago but if it inhabited our oceans
today that would be very bad news much
of the marine life we know today
probably wouldn't exist that's because
the Mosasaur was an incredibly
aggressive predator and would be able to
eat pretty much anything instead the
fish in the sea would need to adapt
special traits in order to avoid the
Mosasaur but how would this giant lizard
affect you well it would make the oceans
a much more dangerous place for humans
we would need massive boats to be able
to fish and swimming and surfing would
be incredibly dangerous
if the Mosasaur found you it would
definitely have you for dinner without a
second thought so have you ever asked
yourself